[Musique]
petite cantate tupou des loups et
obsédant dumas droite montre verte ou
une petite cantate comme nous jouions
autrefois ça le jeu l'ajout maladroite
similaires et son dauphin
cette petite contre force au tofu
n'était pas si me dois de camps
s'étaient tous et notre court et facile
heureuse au bout de dix doigts
moi j'étais là malhabile similar et sans
le dauphin et tu es parti fragiles vers
l'au delà et je reste ma ville faral
d'enfants je te revois souriant assis
devant le piano
dix enfants je joue toi chante chante au
chanteur a pour au moins 6000 récit
minresi son deux roues similaires et
suit le récit sans d'eau au fond mon ami
amadou sur massy petit amour mon dieu
qu'elle est difficile
cette cantate en toi une petite bruine
avec mon coeur pour la faire aimer du
doigt
une partie des meilleurs mais sans un
signe de croix keller france dieu le
père il me le faut
similar et 6000 à risque ferme d'en haut
sybille arrêts similaires et six hommes
dauphin échanges avec leur trompe et
orange remportera
ça te dit tu te contentes que nous
jouions autrefois mésanges avec leur
pomper tout lâche rouge pour toi cette
petite pente au timon seubert quoi
notre petit quant à ceux qui montent
vers toi c'est qu'il aurait semé 9 600
tout fait
[Musique]